♪ Ça va bien aller ♪
- Et c'est un moment spécial,
parce que c'est votre première
entrevue depuis que vous nous
avez inquiétés l'an passé
avec vos ennuis de santé.
Vous avez écrit :
"J'ai failli mourir."
GINETTE RENO, chanteuse
- Oui, par trois fois.
Hum... C'est pas le fun.
Je me rappelle, je suis chez
moi, puis là, je vais tomber...
puis je suis tombée.
Puis là, je fais :
Tu veux vraiment venir
me chercher tout de suite?
Il me semble que j'ai encore
d'autres choses à faire avant,
t'sais. Viens pas me chercher
tout de suite, t'sais.
Mais là, je me suis accrochée
après. Puis là, je suis rentrée
à l'hôpital d'urgence, puis...
Non, parce que c'est pas...
Mais... à chaque fois
que tu reviens, tu fais :
OK... J'ai d'autres
choses à faire.
(applaudissements)
- Pour vos 76 ans,
vous recevez tout un cadeau.
Vous êtes nommée chevalière
de la Légion d'honneur.
- C'est pas de
la petite affaire!
- Qu'est-ce que
ça signifie pour vous?
- C'est gratifiant.
J'adore les trophées,
j'adore les médailles,
j'adore les prix.
Je les prends avec...
Des fois, je me sens
un petit peu mal à l'aise,
mais je les prends avec
tout ce que je peux.
Comme, quand j'étais petite,
j'aimais ça. Ils mettaient
des collants, des affaires,
des images, ils me donnaient
des images ou des petits
collants sur mes...
J'avais l'impression
d'avoir de la valeur.
C'est... c'est gratifiant
pour moi. C'est... puis surtout
que ça vient de l'autre bord,
fait que... ça aussi, c'est
le fun. Ça veut dire qu'il
m'haïssent pas, de l'autre bord,
ils m'aiment aussi.
♪ L'essentiel
c'est d'être aimé ♪
- Vous avez eu tout un succès
en France au fil des ans,
en quoi, en 60 ans de carrière,
plus de 60 ans de carrière.
Comment ça se passait,
e,e,e,e,e, pour vous?
- Mais je sais pas. Des fois,
je me pose la question si
je me suis pas sabotée moi-même.
Parce que je suis une personne
qui a pris beaucoup de poi
À un moment donné, je suis
partie de 117 livres, je suis
montée jusqu'à 306, à p
En ce moment, je pèse 194 livres
et je pense que c'est plutôt
la substance qui a eu le...
C'était comme : Enlevez-moi
tout, mais enlevez-moi pas
ma bouffe. Comme un alcool...
un alcoolique ou un drogué.
Il a fallu que
un... J'ai fait beaucoup
de démarches... beaucoup de...
J'ai fait cinq ans dans
un monastère pour essayer
de découvrir... Puis, c'était
drôle, parce que je me pensais
la plus sensible au mo
puis là, j'ai vu que j'étais pas
toute seule. Il y en a d'autres
qui sont bien plus sensibles
que moi.
- Est-ce que vous vous souvenez
de la journéssssssssssssssée
tous les deux à Boucherville?
- Michel Drucker
vous a surnommée
"la Édith Piaf du Québec".
Vous vous souvenez de ça?
- Parce que je me rappelle
j'avais perdu beaucoup de poids.
Puis, comme j'avais perdu
beaucoup de poids,
je voulais montrer mes cuisses,
parce que je trouvais que
j'avais des belles cuisses!
Mais j'étais jeune aussi, fait
que... Mais lui, il disait :
"Non, non, non, non, non, il ne
faut pas." Parce qu'il disait :
"Le répertoire qtetetetetetetez,
ça n'a rien à voir avec
ce que vous portez! Alors,
vous êtes une Édith Piaf,
vous êtes une Édith Piaf!"
Puis, quand j'ai chanté
dernièrement, je suis allée
il y a quelques années,
on disait : "Édith Piaf
est revenue."
♪ C'est entrer dans son coeur
Et n'en sortir jamais ♪
- Je veux faire un détour
par l'actualité, parce que
la semaine passée, votre ami
Guy Lafleur nous a quittés.
Tout le Québec a été
ému. Comment vous avez vécu ça?
Parce que vous vous êtes côtoyés
pendant... tellement d'années.
- Troublée, troublée,
très troublée. J'ai été...
Bien, chaque fois que j'ai
quelqu'un que j'aime beaucoup,
puis avec qui j'ai...
je suis comme émue. Euh...
Je deviens t
pour un petit bout encore,
je le suis, là...
C'est pas facile.
- Parce que c'est un vrai
gentleman. Tout le monde le dit.
- Ah! Guy... c'est...
C'est un Maurice Richard,
c'est un Ginette Reno,
t'sais, c'est comme...
C'est ça, c'est du vrai monde,
t'sais... C'est... c'est un...
ça, c'étsisisisisisisisisionné.
- La dernière fois qu'on s'est
rencontrés, vous me parliez
d'une autobiographie.
Et de quoi ça va parler?
De quoi vous avez voulu parler
- Bien, ce que ça... ce sera pas
comme une biographie qu'on lit,.
(charabia)
Ça va être surtout
comme de A à Z :
argent, amour, avocat,
boisson, sexe, Dieu.
Fait que là, tu regardes,
admettons... t'sais,
la personne, elle est intéressée
à Dieu : "OK, qu'est-ce qui est
arrivé avec ça?" Fait que là,
c'est écrit : "E
tu en veux à Dieu ou à
ceux qui t'en ont parlé?"
Puis là, ça part, puis
je raconte tout le Dieu vengeur,
le Dieu punisseur que j'avais,
puis comment je m'en suis
fait un qui était mon père,
puis ma m
Après ça, tu dis :
"Bon, le sexe, qu'est-ce
qu'elle a fait? C'est quoi
qu'elle a fait là-dedans?"
Puis, tu vas lire le sexe.
memememememememememe de A à Z.
♪ J'arrive à la fin de ma vie ♪
♪ Comment prendre le tournant ♪
- Et puis, vous avez aussi
un nouvel album et une tournée
aussi pour l'automne.
- Oui.
- Vous manquez pas de travail.
- C'est parce qu'à chaque fois
que je fais quelque chose,
je le fais comme si c'était
la dernière fois. Je suis
un peu comme ça maintenant,
moi, je vis comme si
c'était la dernière fois,
c'est le dernier temps.
C'est la dernière fois que
tu vas chanter? C'est celle-là
que tu vas chanter.
♪ Ça me fait du bien ♪
J'ai le feu sacré.
Le feu, ça crée.
C'est tout.
- Ginette Reno, merci
pour votre générosité.
- C'est moi qui vous remercie.
- Vous avez été un vrai
livre ouvert. Merci.
- Merci, Louis-Philippe. Merci.
♪ Adieu, adieu, je reviendrai
Si je redescends ♪
♪ Sans tomber